what's going on right Riley lupron
what's up how is every little thing
what's going on guys hey yo brah check
[Laughter]
beyond oh man you level
Wow what's going on guys
Rob Cory unite and the Commons roll in
[Laughter]
I'm not playing minesweeper I'm actually
looking at the chat over here Wow
I love your old mega level series oh man
the Rob core rings run on pure marble
phantom yeah they do
they really do it's uh it's kind of
crazy oh wait a minute we almost forgot
something
there we go mm-hmm we forgot my little
my little candle ah can you guys hear me
okay is everything something good all
the audio and everything hopefully it
does rob core powers activating then how
many rays lots of rings oh man is Rob
alone mega level I wished I wish I wish
I was what do you guys think about our
little lamp over there
our little candle thing I think it's
cool I think it's awesome
oh man
it sounds great sounds perfect okay cool
best webcam ever yeah this webcam is
pretty gnarly this webcam is pretty
legit I love this thing so this is this
is a ridiculously good webcam you need a
ring where do we get the rings
where do we get the ring is a juicy
audio see the only thing I don't they
know the only downside of this is if I
post-process this audio it sounds insane
like all the videos of you guys here on
college explain that you've been hearing
for the last month and a half or so have
all come from this microphone right so
it sounds really really good once I get
it you know post process and everything
but when it's just raw audio like this I
don't think it sounds that great I don't
think it sounds very good so you can
actually see the tip of the microphone
right here you have to see it right
there
but uh but yeah yeah this has very very
clean I love this hat oh this is a and
all why Colorado Rockies had it's legit
I love this thing so show you the rain
either way he's actually upstairs ah now
I'm not really worried about copper at
least hopefully doesn't really affect me
too much so which is Lantern would I be
I would be a rock or Lantern so the
clarity is what is Chrome what ever
spent any time in Georgetown and
Georgetown Kentucky yes
enjoy yourself Kentucky it's nice out
there so just the tip it sounds good
actually
okay cool I guess we'll roll with it
then that's that's the case if it sounds
really amazing so umm omega-level voice
uh okay yep I see the mic yeah it's
right here
just a little microphone right there so
um raw uncut is good damn is it really
that good
do you guys really think the audio
sounds this good I mean I don't think it
did but I found sexy as usual oh man I
look like your eldest son man guy vs.
doomsday oh that's a good one I would I
would give it I would give it to
doomsday well I I don't know I might be
kind of an even match right
like is she freaking pregnant Rob I
don't know should I tell you guys for
the number I is pregnant should I drop
the beans on that I don't know if I
should I don't know if I should maybe
I'm not sure man
any underrated comic some would
recommend the witches by Scott Snyder
that's a very underrated comic I'm
surprised I haven't made a show where
I'm moving out of it yet so it sounds
perfectly fine it's on sexy AF man it's
amazing audio okay how many of you guys
want a wild Corinne how many of you guys
want one I feel like people are gonna
say yes if you want a Rob Ford wedding
say me how can how should DC fixer
Cinematic Universe actually wanna make a
video on that so the cat is good cats
down there so um mandalorian I okay I
have not had a chance to watch the
mandalorian yet because every time I try
to play it on Disney plus I like it as a
black screen with sound so it's kind of
a kind of a hassle so
oh man I want one what did I think a
Mandalorian yeah I haven't having that
chance what you get so me I need one I
do oh man you're dying for one you're
dying for Rob Corddry you've been
waiting for over a year
Wow yeah absolute carnage ends I'm
pretty excited about it
like it's it's gonna be kind of nuts
seeing the whole thing come to an end
but I'm really curious to see where it
goes
I'm really excited about that but what I
play minecraft again I didn't know you
guys were interested in me playing
Minecraft so anybody you guys with that
into it so I worked the internet I did
not break the internet the internet
being broken is not my fault oh yeah
I've heard that ever the mandalorian is
really really good I've heard it's
pretty amazing yeah I want to watch it
but it's like oh um what do I think of
the Watchmen
I love the Watchmen like I love the
Watchmen TV show I think it's amazing I
think it's one of the coolest TV shows
out there right now what if scar had
been World Waker he would have quite
literally broken the world he would have
quite literally broken it okay how do
you buy a Rob core ring how do you get
your hands on a Rob Corddry uh what you
are going to do god this camera really
does look good doesn't it it really does
look amazing okay so here's the thing
for those of you guys who follow my
personal Instagram at I am Rob Jefferson
I did this Rob Corinne giveaway right
and the idea was that I've posted up two
pictures every day over the course of
the week and only one of those pictures
had a Rob Corinne in it and so the
objective was to find the Rob core ring
in the picture and and there were there
were people who got to ride people who
are obviously just copying and pasting
what other people said and people who
just got it totally wrong well it was it
was a cool little contest you guys
really really seemed to enjoy this kind
of scavenger hunt for Rob Corey and the
way it worked out who is that those
individuals who who got the correct
answer I would randomly select one of
them and I would give him a rob poor
ring for free right I would I would send
Rob for ring
off to them for free and and as a result
of that it proved to be hugely popular
but the downside of that contest is
there were some people who just couldn't
get their hands on the ring but here's
the here's the issue with the Rob
Corwin's if I announced an Etsy store
right now and I said guys I have an Etsy
store where you can find Rob core rings
if I did that they were to sell out like
that right I wouldn't be able to keep up
with demand it would be it'd be kind of
insane so I've come up with the next
best thing what we're gonna do here is
over my personal Instagram at I am Rob
Jefferson I'm going to do flash sales
and maybe I'll do a flash sale on a
Monday and then maybe I'll do it again
on a Wednesday or maybe I'll do it on
Monday and then I won't do it again for
another week or maybe I won't do it for
another two weeks or something like that
you don't know you never know when those
rings are gonna go on sale right and so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna set it up
because the flash sale is gonna be a
limited number write a small order and
so what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
post up a picture on my Instagram at
some point of a Rob Corley and when I do
your job is to reply to it and when you
reply to it I'll randomly select you
guys those individuals who were selected
can buy one and that's that simple it's
the most reasonable way for me to get
Rob core rings into your hands and be
able to keep up with with demand so uh
yeah it would do it so it would sell out
so incredibly fast right so it's the
only way to release rod core rings and
and get them into your all's hands and
do it in like a reasonable way but other
than that it would be it'd be almost
impossible to do so it would be kind of
nuts it'd be kind of crazy but uh yeah
so if you guys want to be able to hand
on a Rob Corinne go to my personal
Instagram at I am Rob Jefferson and
follow it and then you'll never like
you'll have to keep an eye on it right
because you don't know when a ring will
go on sale but when it does reply to
that and I'll be like okay you win you
know you guys that's good the other
thing that I might do though is I might
say the first 20 people to respond to it
are the ones who can buy but I think I
might randomly select you guys I'm just
kind of you like people who are randomly
selected they can buy a rob court ring
that way I can I can get rings in
y'all's hands cuz I know you guys are
dying for them and and
I can keep up with demand right so
here's the here's the funny thing
here's that here's the here's the funny
thing about this right now I think I
have about how many rings do I have I
think I ordered 200 because I have sizes
7 through 13 I don't have any size 12s
the manufacturer didn't have any size 12
so I couldn't order any size twelves but
I want to say I ordered a thousand rob
quarterings so I have a thousand rings
right now waiting to be sold there's
enough for all of you in this chat right
now so it's cool it's pretty awesome but
uh but yeah so uh here's okay here's a
question here's here's a question I have
for you guys how much do you think the
Rings are gonna cost just type a number
in type a number I already know what
it's gonna be right so I'm not I'm I I'm
not relying on you guys but how much do
you think the Rings are going to be I
think it'd be kind of cool so uh do I
own any pops-up not really I don't
really do you I don't believe you can do
Funko pops I do someone if they come
with something but I've never actually
went out and bought one um I could
there's a huge community forum and
they're usually pretty cool it's just
not really my thing
not really my my own thing so um let's
see Thor with the Thor force versus Odin
with the odinforce uh who do I have Odin
Odin is just that he is that powerful
like it's it's an is insanely powerful
he's insanely powerful so uh as a troll
he respected me well I appreciate that
oh but I am poor Wow people are saying
like $100 Jesus if we were saying like
200 no they're not gonna be $200 that's
crazy
they're not even gonna be $100 that's
insane that's absolutely ridiculous I
would never charge $100 for a rock or I
guess I could the like Victoria hundred
dollars for in a lead ring right I could
change the color up and just be like
okay so like you can be a member of the
Rob core you know but then like if you
have this ring you're an elite member of
robbed core like a super member of the
rob court that'd be kind of nuts do i
watch iew yes um here's the thing I'm
hoping aw gets their hands on ricochet
from WWE because he's a cool wrestler
but I feel like he's the most underused
town the WWE has at the moment ricochet
is amazing he's he's so cool to watch ah
Deadshot vs Deathstroke who would win I
think Deathstroke because of the healing
factor um he need a size nine and a half
all I have are full sizes right so seven
eight nine ten eleven and thirteen I
don't really have half sizes or anything
like that
so a lot of the fans who won them who
had like half sizes like 11 and a half
or 12 and a half or something like that
um we just sent one size up that way we
won't have to worry about it like crush
and you can always go and get it resized
as well right so um let's see you can't
wait to finally get a ring man $100 Wow
yeah they would debut like yeah alpha
rob court rings there we go alpha rob
court rings here's a question what color
should the alpha rob core rings be
because the rob court rings right now
the regular color is gray so what do we
like the Alpha Rob core rings like what
color do we makes it okay here's what we
do the the Alpha Rob core rings it is a
gray background with a with a white with
the white Rob core symbol we could
switch it up we could make it a white
background with a gray Rob core symbol
right and I that makes you an elite
member of the Rob core it'd be kind of
cool they'll be pretty awesome oh man um
what's our rob4 oath okay hold on a sec
it's like let me find it let me find it
and I will post up the Rob Kouros Rob
people are already searching for Rob
core rings for sale on Google maybe
they've been searching for it I don't
know okay ah the Rob Kouros let's drag
this out so we can type it out in the
chat and away we go
okay I'm one of those away for me to pin
my own comment actually we're going to
post it in the description and then you
guys can just refresh the stream
I'm typing it out now and then what
we'll do is once all you guys refresh
will read over it together which I think
would be pretty cool we can all recite
the oath together man aside and fight
okay okay here's what I need you guys to
do I need all of you
okay changes are being saved changes are
being save all changes safe okay all of
the guys refresh the stream just hit
refresh on your on your browser iron AB
Batman vs iron man who wins uh that's a
good one um honestly I would pick Batman
because it was ingenuity because of his
intelligence so I can't copy and paste
it because it's uh it's not having
impassable so um okay yeah that was my
first thought was a copy and paste but I
don't have it written down anywhere
writing copy and then paste it so I do
feel like a newb I do feel like a newb
okay let me know when you guys when you
guys see the robbed Court Oath down
there just say I see it just type that
just type that in the chat just type
then I see it nice bouquet yeah this is
this doesn't that stuff at one point
four so what's going on lol SD ninja why
did you pick that name oh man these vs.
not sewins
Man Tony Stark is smarter you think Tony
Stark's 20s are smart but he's not the
smartest person in the Marvel Universe
I'm pretty sure Bruce Wayne's the
smartest person in the DC Universe maybe
Lex Luthor had
though um I see it I see it
okay uh-huh that sweet I'm sorry 13 him
yep I see it okay
everybody sees it people are still
refreshing it looks like I see it I see
it oh thank you
am i new to the show and hers wrote
books I'm curious is that true oh yeah I
wrote a book yeah yeah I did write a
book on the history of Superman should
make you a race to match my thumbnails
Thor force vs. hero kala that's a good
one I would actually say the Thor force
I think we're pretty cool hero kyle is
powerful but the Thor force is just like
infinite power for Thor it's kind of
crazy so I see it okay nice I see that
how's life life is good life is very
good life is very much good life is all
about chillin and relaxin chillin out
maxin relaxin all cool okay Oh Duncan or
Krispy Kreme Krispy Kreme and not even
either of those um spottings Donuts in
Lexington in Lexington Kentucky is
amazing okay you guys ready to read The
Rock Court Oath you guys ready to read
this rob Kouros why don't I do this
weekly um I'm actually gonna start doing
on my patreon uh let's see okay beware
Rob sexy voice okay if you guys are
ready to be the Rob Court Oath just say
yes the way Rob sighs oh man Rob vs. all
where's a good place to start reading
comics again you've been behind for
about three years
well pick your favorite character and
just kind of go forward from there um if
it's if it's Captain America I would
start with Nick Spencer's Captain
America run you could go all the way
back to Ed Brubaker which is kind of
important given what's going on right
now in Tallahassee coach
which is probably the best Captain
America run like the best kind of book
out there and nobody's reading this it's
absolutely amazing like Tallahassee
codes Captain America is awesome it's so
cool but but yeah so um okay people are
saying yes people are saying yes okay
let us read this rob Court Oath from
pages small to screen of bright no
Comics shall escape my sight let those
who choose a side and fight beware my
power the rod coil light
that's an awesome oh I love that oath is
actually a fan it's one of you guys who
thought it up it was amazing it was
absolutely amazing
but I hope you guys enjoyed saying it as
much as I did oh it was really cool my
cuts around here somewhere she's roaming
around doing whatever cats do so she's
just roaming around being a cat let's
see I'm glad this isn't a nice
translator from let's see you just got
here what's going on I'm sorry Grodd
poor rings on my personal Instagram and
I am rob Jefferson I'm going to post up
a picture of me with the robbed poor
mean it's just gonna go to it might just
be a picture of a robbed core ring and
then you have to reply to it and so
though I'm gonna pick 20 people out of
those replies and I'm gonna sell rings
to them so yeah it's the only way to
really do it and keep up with demand
which is cool it's actually really fun
so okay
here's a question I have for you guys
right someone on patreon right now you
get all like like all the uncensored
video so like the boys uncensored and
I'm gonna start doing other comics that
I can't really do here on YouTube
especially now because of Coppa because
like the child online privacy protection
thing YouTube is super hardcore cracking
down on like family-friendly stuff so I
can't really upload I can't really make
public like non family-friendly things
right um and so even even with the boys
right now is kind of stretching alright
like I had a couple videos that were
like demonetized that I had to go back
and and get sorted out so it's kind of
turning the line and I've kind of been
told by a reliable source hey make sure
you're careful about that
you might run into trouble so I'm gonna
take all the uncensored videos and I'm
gonna start putting them on patreon
right that cost like a buck it's like a
dollar a month for for like uncensored
videos and things um and then for five
bucks a month it's all the vs. videos
and then what I was curious about with
you guys and I want to ask you guys
about this would you guys pay $15 a
month for my videos ad free to get my
videos without any advertisements would
you pay 15 bucks a month for that let me
know down in the let me let me know in
the thing just said yes or no I'm kind
of curious because I'm interested in
doing it um but I also want to make sure
if something that people are interested
in because the amount of work that goes
into it right because we got to take the
videos and we'd have to upload them onto
like a throwaway channel right cuz I
can't undo ads on a comic explain and
then like I won't have a home and I
won't be able to take care of my family
or anything so I'd have to upload them
onto a throwaway channel and then just
put them directly onto on the patreon
link on the patreon because patreon the
video max um
patreon is video max doesn't doesn't
allow for like the size of the videos
that I could that I could upload so um
but yeah so anyone answer the marquee of
death versus the void yes you're very
curious thority of death the marquee of
death definitely so you already don't
get ahead oh man that's a no yeah no
it's fine if you say no I mean I'm not
gonna hold it against you I'm not gonna
be like bands like I'm not gonna do that
I was just curious what your all stance
was you know I was curious
ah let's see well they haven't gone live
on Instagram yet so now it would be all
the videos right so would be a
combination of the full story videos and
it would be my regular videos and they
would all go live without without any
kind of yeah the the the hero hero guys
I'm on cut is on patreon but it'll be
all my videos um like all the videos so
everything for like the multi our full
story videos all the way to like my
regular videos all would be at free on
on patreon and I was curious if that's
something that you guys would pay for so
well it's career so that's that's
something you guys have paid 15 bucks
for it but ah favorite upcoming Marvel
movie shang-chi I'm actually excited fat
here's the kitty
here's my kitty here she is Doomsday
Clock yeah I'm waiting for Doomsday
Clock number number 12 to come out like
everybody else three years late yeah I'm
waiting on that oh man
I mean if that's the case I would I
would okay so that's that's a good
question would you guys pay 15 bucks a
month for early access and for no ads on
my videos would you guys do that that's
a question asked that's that's that
would be interesting to see if you guys
would do that so I'm just trying to get
a feel for what kind of stuff you guys
are interested in in terms of patreon so
I figured the best way to do that was to
reach out to you guys and ask you and so
I figure we find out from there but um
but yeah so I want to ring because one
of the things that I kind of have to
contend with and that's why I'm kind of
on the fence about 15 watch maybe it's
something like $10 or something like
that it's because what I'm basically
doing is I'm competing with streaming
services now right so you've got Disney
Plus and you probably got Amazon you got
Hulu so like that so the question is is
the content that I put on YouTube is it
comparable to what you get with all
those streaming so and is it worth it
right that's the kind of question you
have to ask from a financial perspective
so but yeah so mm-hmm
how early of access are probably about a
week or two weeks maybe so hmm go kid
like ultra instinct Goku ultra against
teen Goku is basically ultra plop
armored Goku that's basically what that
is so um what do you mean stop asking
the same questions over and over ITAT uh
no way I'm down with that right because
like if some of those questions don't
get answered so as a result of that like
they kind of have to ask multiple times
but um okay I'm not I'm not selling the
Rings through patreon I thought about
that but the issue is trying to keep up
with demand right because if I if I say
like a ring it's like five bucks on
patreon um and I have to do is I joined
up for a dollar so I'm like that people
will join up and then as soon as I get
the Reno leave but then I'll get like so
many people who want rings I won't be
able to
with demand right like I'd get like
maybe 200 people who all join up and
then buy a Rob core ring and then like
I'll be sending them out forever right
so you know I think doing it on
Instagram is the most effective way to
sell them at a reasonable price that you
guys can afford and then turn out cuz
they're gonna be 30 bucks you know so
Suliman a reasonable price that you guys
can afford and then and then turn around
and be able to keep up with demand so ah
your cat versus my cat oh man
but yeah so you heard there were rings
because one thing I thought about doing
too is if I was gonna charge people to
get my videos ad free then there'd be ad
free there'd be early access and then I
may put like the original like the old
intro I may put it like in the front of
it and just throw it out there and be
like you get you get like the old like
you get the old intro like the old
shortchange hero intro and then you get
the video add for you any good early
right so I'm kind of curious why did one
of the things that I've that I do know
about with with patreon is usually
bundling things together is what people
love right like bundling things out
doing multiple things for a single tier
that way it's worth the investment right
you know it's worth it's worth doing
with regard to that whole investment
instead of just like a single thing like
one single thing so you know um let's
see yeah I'm actually gonna sell the Rob
Corey's on my personal histogram this
week so probably tomorrow or the day
after is what I'm gonna do the first
sale so let's see which Marvel
characters need a buff Oni a buff like
need to become stronger hmm can I say
man let me tell you something man which
characters need a buff
hmm yeah a lot of people miss your old
intro uh which characters that's a good
question which characters need a buff an
increase in strength and marvel I mean
there's spider-man but spider-man's
spider-sense is really what keeps him
ahead of a lot of the characters who are
out there if spider-man lost like if you
if you beefed up spider-man's power
he'd kind of be overpowered right like
he'd be powerful enough to take on
pretty much anybody and to be able to
dodge them because of his spider sense
uh maybe Captain America maybe give
Captain America a power increase so gore
is powerful enough as it is I took Thor
from three generations to kill that guy
like to defeat that guy so like he uh
he's kind of he's already pretty
powerful
Shazam he's basically Superman Shazam is
already pretty overpowered hmm the og
intro music was the best yeah what I'm
trying to do I mean if I'm being honest
with you guys what I'm trying to do with
patreon is is do it in such a way to
where things are bundled together so you
guys feel rewarded right like that's one
of the reasons why I'd like to doing all
the the uncut videos for like a buck
right because I mean technically they
come out every week but it's super cheap
to write so you can get like all kinds
of different video you can get all the
uncut videos uncensored all that kind of
stuff we're like I mean like in the boys
like on the videos on patreon like
there's all kinds of you know things in
there you know that I wouldn't normally
be able to put on the regular YouTube
channel I like doing stuff like that
once you start getting into higher tiers
and you start charging people like 5
bucks a month 10 bucks and 115 bucks a
month or 20 bucks a month you gotta like
yes we done it away tour it makes it
worth their while right so I'm trying to
I'm trying to think of things I mean
what suggestions do you guys have that's
actually good idea like what things do
you like what things would you guys pay
like 10 bucks a month for on patreon
your collection of the Rings like the
lantern colors that we've got a cool but
captain carrot
captain care is a super bunny did
Allegiant just end
I thought Legion ended a while ago I'm
very excited about spider about spiders
too I'm very excited about some
adversity oh man yeah I'm very happy to
ask my new verse to you so whatever
happened to the merged century I don't
know Jeff let me wrote the story he took
off into space we haven't seen or heard
from him since so I have no clue where
we're merged century is but let's see uh
people are just like people are just
constantly posting up the same comments
just like standing the same comments oh
[Laughter]
man ah let's see oh we already the the
rapport oh there's actually in the
description we already ran over that so
you'll use Instagram happy to get a ring
um actually instagrams the only way that
I'm doing it right it's the only way
that would get I'm selling rapport rings
so alright Legion ended a month or two
but that's what I thought it ended a
little while ago so I mean it was cool
you know I don't think they started to
back up so um let's see the void in the
century molecule man versus dr.
Manhattan my sports fan yes I'm
definitely a sports fan I am a huge
sports fan I mean this is what happens
when we livestream know guys like a
zillion people show up and they all
start asking questions and things like
that so there's really no way to get
around it but I do love the HBO Watchmen
series well you guys have asked me that
already but I do love the HBO Watchmen
series so 37 hours explaining why
Marvel's age of Ultron event was a
massive win uh let's see I mean okay
what do you guys think about Watchmen
actually asked answering that question
what're you guys think about the
Watchmen it's kind of a cool question to
ask independent comic recommendation
east of West by Jonathan Hickman
southern bastard
by Jason Aaron those are really really
good ones let's see this century versus
no no that's gonna be a gun he's
literally a multiversal being like it's
insane how powerful he is let's see how
would new the end I don't know what that
is
I've needs to chill Marcos Rivera's is
getting so bent out of shape over the
chat it's kind of crazy a patreon
exclusive Q&A that's actually gonna do a
live stream directly on patreon and then
upload the archive onto YouTube that'd
be a cool it'd be cool to go on
peachy-pink he'll already again that was
a really cool show do is do you guys a
favor and make a comic for myself I
don't really want to make a comic book I
don't really have a desire to make a
comic book no I'm not really watching
any anime at the moment uh let's see oh
that was the one about asked me to make
you like Watchmen it's really
interesting so far yeah I loved it I did
not buy the Infinity box saga no I need
I need to I need to buy the infinity
sign up box
I have not bought that yeah but I want
to cuz I like I like oh my owning movies
on blu-ray I'm like physical blu-ray
right because physical blu-ray always
looks better especially like like Ultra
HD and 4k and like physical discs always
look better than streaming they always
look better in the streaming they have
like every time so okay um no I don't
have a discord I don't want to use
discord so okay um guys I'm gonna go
ahead and bounce off here um this has
been fun it's cool chitchat with you all
talking to you guys um it's it's it's
it's cool like I enjoyed this so anyway
uh
go ahead and bounce off here I'm gonna
spit ball some ideas over at people on
on patreon kind of see what they think
um if you guys are interested see me
send me some emails Rob at comics
explain calm and just harlot patreon
ideas and just throw me some ideas I've
got some ideas of my own but I'm also
curious to see what you guys want to see
like what you guys are interested in
seeing on patreon so anyway you guys I'm
gonna go ahead and ounce off here and uh
yeah I will catch you all later
who's